Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Full Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 3 Video. There were
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
Unity finally came back after season 2.
Been a while since we've seen her.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
Careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot,
Talking about Easter eggs wtf moments
starting with the episode title Air Force Wong,
which is a reference to both Air
Force One, the movie with Harrison Ford
in Doctor Wong, Rick's therapist.
It was a really big Dr.
Wong episode, in addition to a big unity
in a big President episode,
the cold open starts with Rick
getting another therapy session with Dr.
Wong using a hologram so that he can find
a bag of Funyuns that he left behind the couch
because apparently he goes to therapy so often
that he needs snacks just to make it through.
He gets so hungry.
there was a big therapy bit
running through the episode.
The whole idea that Rick has slowly
been working on himself
since the last Unity episode in season two in.
He's been doing so much therapy,
like he spent so much time
at therapy that he needs snacks
just to make it to the end.
they were also really specific
by using the Funyuns,
like they mentioned the Funyuns
a couple of times, Normally brands of food
or drinks in the Rick and Morty Universe
or the Rick and Morty Multiverse
tend to be generic parodies of real life brands
there are couple exceptions to that rule,
though,
like during season three,
they did the McDonald's Sichuan sauce.
they start the whole bit with the president
being horny for Dr.
Wong when he shows up to get Rick's help
with another disaster.
The first time in the episode he's
helping out with the Loch Ness Monster,
which they canonize to Rick and Morty.
Like there are a bunch of monsters
that they canonize in this.
both Reagan,
the president have special identifiers
for each other on their phones,
like on the president.
It just says U.S.
president with a symbol for the president
like a shield and an eagle.
but on the president's phone,
he actually has a picture of them killing
the Loch Ness monster as his lockscreen
in the subtitle reading God Damn Spaceman.
I think they're just mostly meant
to be a metaphor about their relationship.
Like they both hate each other,
but they also like each other a lot too,
because they do make peace
at the end of the episodes.
that's
pretty much the arc of their relationship
through all of their previous episodes
together.
Dr. Wong suggests,
Rick, these people to think that he's cool
when he mentions the president is calling him.
They actually reference this earlier
this season two.
Like the whole idea is that Rick actually
does care about what people think of him.
He talked about creating a mystique
around himself so that people feared him more.
they wind up using that concept
for the president's whole arc in this episode.
And now he desperately needs approval.
You could call that a joke, like them
clowning on pretty much any U.S.
president in history,
when Rick jokes about her working extra hard
because she wants to earn more money
at the end of the episode,
they wind up paying this off
because she winds up
giving therapy sessions to rig the president
and unity to save the planet,
earning a ton of money, sending the bill
to the government because it's so big.
but the real thing about Rick though is it
isn't actually care
about the acquisition of wealth
but he doesn't care about actual literal money.
any time he would really need something
he could actually just created
end, even though they make a big deal
about the President and Dr.
Wong being on a first name basis in the episode
we learned his full name was Andre Curtis
a couple of seasons ago,
and I think this is the first episode though,
when we learned Doctor Wong's
first name is Helen.
look in the background.
You notice
they change the poster outside of her office.
It's just a regular family with the dedication
theme.
It's just meant to be a reference to Rick
being dedicated to his family
previously the poster was all about courage.
With someone eating a hot dog.
It was meant to be a joke about Golden Fold
uncontrollably eating his own poop
like have courage to not eat your own poop
this a big
info dump on the Loch Ness monster
in the Rick and Morty Universe?
In this reality, the Loch Ness monster is real,
not just a myth.
In 1961,
Now we're talking about the Cold War era here
because they talk about the Soviets
as part of its back story during the Cold War,
the CIA moves the Loch Ness Monster to Lake
Erie in Ohio, replaces her bones with titanium.
She was bit by werewolves.
Werewolves also now Ken into the Rick
and Morty multiverse turning her into a aware
Loch Ness monster,
which they use as an anti-submarine weapon.
and because we're still in the middle of the
Cold War era Like this is so a long time ago.
In the past, The Soviets deploy a leprechaun
to stop her Leprechauns
also now,
Ken, into the Rick and Morty multiverse, even
though we saw one on interdimensional cable
that was from another universe,
they turn its bones into silver,
which they call the Loch Ness
monster version of AIDS.
Getting trapped on the bottom of the ocean
until present day when she's risen
angry and looking for food and revenge.
no joke.
I actually had to rerecord
that part of the video
like a couple of times because I couldn't
stop laughing.
see if you can recite the president's
entire explainer for the Loch Ness Monster
without cracking up.
you notice, while the president is explaining
everything, Rick
is casually eating the Funyuns
still like he could barely be bothered.
Mostly he's just going. What?
The president is an excuse to get out of there.
Be they start one of what becomes
many Scientology jokes during the episode,
Rick is also apparently a huge fan
of Tom Cruise, big fan of the Mission
Impossible movies, probably
that's mostly just a reference to Tom Cruise
being one of the most famous Scientologists
on the planet.
the space Mormon reference
is to the origins of Scientology
and how a lot of their beliefs reference aliens
And the president is correct
when he says that therapy is working on Rick
as he quickly
takes back his joke on silly religions.
none of the intro
scenes are featured in this episode.
So maybe we'll see one at some point
in one of the future episodes this season.
we're still only in episode three right now,
so there's still plenty of opportunities
when they go back to their house,
they're watching interdimensional cable
in a TV show with Mr.
Stabby, who has arms and legs that are swords.
The whole bit is that he just stabs
all of his audiences.
Everybody that comes to his show winds up dying
they way of turning into a much larger bit
about fame obsessed culture in reality shows
wanting attention, even if it's bad attention.
I didn't sense any direct
parodies of actual real life
TV shows with the swords, four arms and legs.
But if you did sense any,
just write it below in the comments.
when the president starts making fun of Morty
telling him to shut up,
he's always been like that.
Like he doesn't like Morty that much.
But generally this episode, the president
is a way bigger dick than in previous episodes.
they revealed that Bigfoot exists.
And he lives in Montana.
the whole bit about the Nazis in America
is like a right wing political joke
that people talk about in real life
when he tries is general about the bit like,
not you too.
This is a joke
about how a lot of people on his staff
are also probably right wing Virginia's state
motto is actually, Virginia is for lovers,
which they use for the unity storyline.
she basically takes over the state
just because she's
waiting for an opportunity
to talk to Rick about his hunt for Rick.
Prime that was the person quote unquote
that he was searching for that
she wanted to talk to to do.
They didn't actually mention Rick prime
by name, but that's who she was referencing.
but the whole idea is that she winds up
turning the state into a utopia.
And this is also a joke during season two, in
that previous Unity episode, the whole idea is
that she's this dangerous space monster
wanting to consume the entire universe.
but the way they make
it seem is almost like life
is better under her than it is with free will.
they're actually getting
into this whole concept during Loki season two
with Loki arguing that the TVA is necessary
to control people's free
will in order to help maintain the multiverse
and keep it from destroying itself.
they make the first of many digs
at the president's approval rating,
which is a 25% in for reference,
even the most hated U.S.
presidents in real life had approval ratings
that were way higher than this.
So the whole idea
is that the country really hates the president.
Notice that the president also calls his staff
by their first names,
paying off the first names bit
just a little bit more
what he says America knows
and incinerates colts when they see them.
It's just meant to play into his whole trigger
happy attitude during the episode, making it
sound like he almost wants another civil war,
which he shouts out later on the news.
Like he offers Dr.
Wong a gun as if it's a stick of gum.
The crack team he puts together of the aliens
in the artificial intelligence
is an elaborate ploy to get Dr.
Wong's phone number because he's super horny.
you can let me know in the comments.
If you think the aliens are specific references
to any other pop culture stories, movies
or TV shows.
But I felt like that artificial intelligence
was a reference
to HAL 9000 from 2001 Space Odyssey Notice
when Rick says 3 billion women on the planet
have nothing to do with him in real life,
there are 3.95 billion women on the planet,
meaning that about 950 million women
have something to do with Rick,
that means that he really, really gets around
Fleet Flag warns Rick again about Bigfoot,
but he's not going to Montana.
So I think the whole idea is that
he's just really bad at his job.
then we get a bunch more back story about Dr.
Wang she used to do
field studies in grad school
and she was super freaky,
which the president obviously very happy about.
maybe you could call that a joke
about Susan Sarandon's previous movies
she made when she was younger.
And if you didn't realize Dr.
Wong is voiced by Susan Sarandon in real life,
they actually explained that the reason
she wound up on the show back
during Season three is because
her grandchildren
are super fans of Rick and Morty.
So she just did it to make them happy.
the when the governor tries to turn
the president away, it's actually because unity
was only there to wait for an opportunity
to talk to Rick about primary.
She didn't want to take over
the entire country.
So she was just trying to contain herself
to the state of Virginia.
then they start making more jokes
about how things would be better under a unity
like you don't need free.
Well, things would be way better with her
around and making a bunch of communism jokes
when the president references the government
getting into a war with the state, he's
talking about the actual civil war,
which he references later in the episode,
the Make another Scientology joke
when they reference unity being a body
snatching hive mind and a Will Smith joke
that's because his wife, Jada Pinkett
Smith, is a Scientologist or she was one,
and he was hoping to use his secret serviceman
as an excuse to meet them
there are a lot of celebrities in real life
who are Scientologists.
Then nudity comes back.
We haven't seen her since season two.
I don't think that they've referenced her
that many times either.
Like, there've been a couple references,
but this is the first time
that she's actually come back in a big way
as a character.
And it is Christina Hendricks
who's coming back to voice the character
the reason why she said she came back
is because she found out through the grapevine,
so to speak, across the multiverse
that Rick was looking for Rick prime again
in apparently they introduced
this cannon, this backstory
that predates the events of season one.
They're basically explaining
more of his history with Rick Prime.
So the idea is that at some point
Rick was dating unity
like they were actively together
before the events of season one in while
that was happening he was on the hunt
for Rick Prime and he almost wound up dying.
so now in present day
unity found out that he's looking for him again
and is coming to warn him to stop so
that he doesn't wind up getting himself killed.
Most of this, I think, is just to hype up
a big battle between
the two of them at some point later
this season, like maybe the finale.
she left him a couple messages,
which he did not answer.
So she was so worried about him
that she just came in, posted up
in Virginia,
waiting for an opportunity to talk to him.
Rick reveals that after the events
of season two, when they broke up,
he created an anti unity gun that he could
spray people with to keep her away,
basically revealing how bitter
he is about their break up
still in present day, even though he's slowly
been working on himself.
Like emotionally, he has grown as a person,
but he's still really,
really pissed off about it.
we find out that Dr.
Wong is just a nutritionist.
She's not an actual psychologist or psychiatry,
but the whole bit
with putting the energy dome over
the city is a reference to The Simpsons.
They basically put a dome over
the city of Springfield.
It's also been referenced in a lot of sci
fi stories, like movies, TV shows.
So it's actually a pretty common thing
the president also implies
that he has domes like this
ready around every single state inside the U.S.
then the news anchor.
Shonda basically references
most of the president's episodes in the past,
all the disasters during each of them,
not every episode, but most of his episodes.
the alien invasion she starts with
was his first episode Get Swifty.
The mutant turkeys were from season four.
The White House in Space was from
their big Star Wars parody in season six,
saying that it's still up there in orbit and
they just built another White House after that.
the ego
conscious dinosaurs were also from season six.
I did full episode
breakdown videos Easter eggs for all those.
So I'll put links for that stuff
down the description below He reveals
his mother is dead and he hated her, which
they turned into a bigger therapy joke with Dr.
Wong like, I'm obsessed with my mother
and have a bad relationship with her.
It's probably bad for our relationship.
they kind of implied that Dr.
Wong was about to get with the president
until he went off the deep end of crazy
during the episode And when Rick whips out
all of his Inspector Gadget weapons,
most of the weapons are similar to previous
episodes with one exception like Zuma enhancer.
this is actually a copy of a United States
voting ballot info sheet.
You get these
when you vote in presidential elections.
Is it just a joke about Rick
voting the president out of office?
it'll be interesting to see if he just remains
president through the entire run of Rick and
Morty, like season ten, season 20, however long
they wind up going, because usually U.S.
presidents can only serve for up
to eight terms.
Theoretically because we only saw him
as the president in season three
for the first time, they could actually have
him still be the president in season
11 and have it make sense
the make a joke about America's military tech
being made of shoddy workmanship,
but China being a way bigger threat.
Ricketts pisses the president when he starts
making fun of unity, showing
that he's still kind of in love with her.
They also make it seem like
he wants to get back together with her
at the end of the episode, but understands
when she's not having it
That's also meant to be another reference
to his therapy sessions actually working
like he's
actually able to make it through that.
Whereas during the events in season two,
after they broke up, he tried to kill himself.
Dr. Wong basically breaks up with the President
who he then kicks out telling her to use the
secret exit of the White House in the women's
bathroom, which is used mostly for workers.
In another joke about the Kennedy sex tunnels
from back in season three, as he says,
they also get used a lot, meaning
there are a ton of those kinds of women,
quote unquote, that make it in
and out of the White House secretly.
turns out the US president gets around
almost as much as Rick does
there are bunch of but play jokes too.
Losing a finger in action
must be some hardcore or fun times.
Do you like the metaphors that they make?
Pretty obvious
when Rick comes back to the garage and starts
working on this device, he's working on it
a couple of times in the episode.
You can let me know in the comes
what you think it is.
It looks kind of like a bong,
but then it kind of disappears
later in the episode,
like we don't know where it winds up going
when the president takes the giant bomb
to the dome, it looks kind of like a Dr.
Strangelove reference
just because they do a lot of Dr.
Strangelove references when they show
the White House bunker here in the war room.
because the dome is more of a Simpsons parody.
They actually did the Dr.
Strangelove joke with the bomb
during The Simpsons episodes.
hee! Hijacks the hive
in order to push his approval rating to 100%.
And Rick's gimmicks that he mentions to unity
are just the storytelling tropes of movies
and TV shows where characters will just show up
out of nowhere, like break the laws of physics,
super fast travel system.
they kind of did this
during the Game of Thrones later seasons
where characters
would just travel all over Westeros super fast
in a way that wouldn't make sense.
she mentions the phone messages
she left for him, which they play
at the end of the episode.
In The cardinal mistake that Dr. Wong
commits is by saying that
one of them is wrong and one of them is right.
Normally in a situation like this,
neither one of them would be right.
And neither one of them will be wrong.
Dr. Wong basically helps communicate to unity
that Rick has become a better person.
He's grown emotionally as a person
since the events of season two when they broke
up and unity invades Earth to help save it.
they pay off the bill with Dr. Wong
earning a ton of money
by sending the bill to the Government.
Like I said, though, Rick doesn't really care
about actual money the way they end things
with unity, she leaves
like they'll keep in touch at some point.
We'll probably see her
come back in a future season.
They reveal
Rick has a secret stash of beer.
Zoom and enhance...
He's also got
what looks like a container of ice cream.
Some red fluid with a creature floating in it.
I can't tell what it is. And something
with those green containers,
you can let me know what you think
those are in the comments below.
but basically showing
how much Rick has grown as a person.
He takes the beer to the president
to console him because of their respective
love lives being in the dumps.
Last time he tried and failed to kill himself.
They also pay off the Scientology bit
with the voicemail, trying to recruit him,
implying that the Scientologists were listening
in on his conversations during the episode.
like they heard quote unquote,
that he was referencing Scientology.
Like all we heard
you were saying nice things about us, meaning
that they are monitoring what everyone says.
also making a John Travolta joke
because he's also a famous Scientologist
during the post-credits scene.
They do a big Larry King
interview, bit with Mr. Stabby.
Coming back is more commentary
on fame obsessed culture
in doing anything for attention at any cost.
Like, Well, you're paying attention to me,
even though I am killing my entire audience,
58,000 people
also trying to justify what he's doing
because he is a minority, under-represented,
because he has arms and legs
that are swords there are a bunch of Easter
eggs and references in the episode.
So if he spotted any
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
In my episode 4 video will post next week
Big reminder too, is that Invincible season
2 episodes start this week.
I'll be doing weekly videos for that.
It is probably one of the best series
on television right now.
Not just best superhero series,
which is best series in general.
Click Here for my Invincible Season 2
trailer video and click here
for all my Rick and Morty episodes.
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!